it's late summer and there's not a tree
nor a bush nor a blade of grass here at
1,300 meters mountain guide Georg zu
Schmidt knows every rock on the how to a
fell on the Norwegian Finnish border
there's been a move afoot here to move
the border standing here on the Finnish
Hal T here to the right you see the
border marker it's the highest point in
Finland if you look towards the other
side it gets higher and that's Norway so
Finland's highest peak has a Norwegian
summit how annoying that a mountain peak
in otherwise very flat Finland has its
summit outside the country across a
border drawn in 1740 the oddity was
first noticed by bérenger harsh on a
long-standing staff member of the
Norwegian mapping Authority he'd been
investigating some peculiar features of
the boundary line on the holiday and
decided this would be an ideal time to
correct them we tried to let the
Norwegian government give it as a gift
from the Norwegian people to Finland in
accordance in in relation to their
100-year celebration as a free nation
his main supporter is Spain oddvar Laros
mayor of the municipality at the foot of
the how t he picked up on the idea and
wrote an official request to the prime
minister in Oslo she sent an equally
official response that the Constitution
wouldn't allow Norway to cede any of its
territory with kind regards ernesto berg
says no then as mayor of the Cofield
municipality i have to respect that but
maybe they'll reconsider it's a matter
of an area of half the size of a soccer
field the border marker will just have
to be moved a few metres
it's claimed that a compromise might be
possible a swap would not violate the
Constitution Finland would get the
summit and give a piece of wasteland to
Norway in exchange after all Norway has
no real use for the haughty the
Norwegians have plenty of other Peaks to
climb and the Finns didn't even get the
top of this pile of rocks we're standing
on here I think that's too bad the poor
face and what do the Finns say about the
issue do they really want the additional
8 meters of summit from that side of the
border it's quite a long way to the
nearest habitation there may well be
more reindeer than people in the area
then finally 59 kilometres from the how
to a Finnish village I think it is very
good reason to give to Finland because
we are good neighbor of Norwegian and
many people come to Finland because that
more tourists yes yes more tourists I
love the idea but even nowadays it
doesn't matter when you are top on the
holiday that which side you want and
guide georg sickish MIT thinks the move
just might turn the barren fell into a
tourist magnet that's wouldn't a truly
of course it would make this peak more
popular especially in Finland more
Finn's would come here just to climb
their highest mountain making a present
of a mountain top could mean a small
boost to Nordic tourism but it could
also send a message to the world that
was the original intention Norway also
give the Peace Prize the Nobel Peace
Prize every year and we could go
had like a good example on how you can
treat your neighbor by giving phenom
lists this little piece of land Finland
will be celebrating the centenary of its
independence in December who knows by
then with luck the country's highest
peak could be a little higher